зло чини профілю dynasty на
окупованих територіях
на ікри чучхе порушення правлю девід
буваєте в кремах районах донецької та
луганської областей та в криму кажи
корівник адвокат нового центру
українського хельсінського спілки виправлю
ден і бурою захарів
тут люди покликала не своїх базових прав
за крима право на жити про руїну
житло
ви кран данік від рівня порушення
романських політичних то
соціально-економічних прав
дискримінація свободи совісті з це
будда немає окупованих територій
порушення права переселенців внутрішнього
приміщення собою за законом за ви не від
рима ти допомогу процесу що ванні за
б поспішайте від них вартовим же клон
мати зможу продовжити їзду бути а у
светр проте правозахисники фіксує
створа немає так і таких перепад ось
прямо не адреса але й грушева допомога
а також сад ринку взяти тебе на вигляд
просив intel в українську хельсинську
spills виправлю дена на калош ще
держава поки ти можеш ви вирішите
проблеми соціалізації переселенців
у повному масштабі на ефективність
українська влада
на ефекти і знову досліджуючи викладену
про ти майдані активів у скільки на травень
акорди нації деймеш з особистими органами
такого ви знову куди йшла експерт з
консультативної групи рада Європи все у
2015 уроки ж тодес нічного прориву
розслідування на увазі у лося
неефективно розслідуєте як праворуч
хитрий малий су стильний резонанс так
імідж resonance не експерт українська
алексінська спилка виправлю ден і
михайло тарах кола помил q і реформи мвс
називаючи Віттіг до досконалих сліпих і
криміналістів за словами правозахисника
на ви старша з жахливого
експертно-криміналістичного обладнання
то викрав знатних знаємо проти ти не
на нижню риму можуть не ув'язніть головна
проблема змусили читати в'язниць
українській пенітенціарній системі за
словом і правозахисники і чи будемо сізо
і місця вид б ваня покарання як він і по
50 та по 100 рокер і змусили приміщення
на вигляд побачить з жахливими muhammad пику
необхідного для днів і крижини
то санітарним але
мама навик вона не рішення національних
судимий за словом і михаїла тарах колодязя
проблема з але я з перших денна
важливості України та переважно ціни
Викладення рішення суду їх бурхливий
кому виступає держава тихіше та жебрака
держави та органи про досвід спадкоємства
і стоїть сотні подібних праворуч душа паші
ранню практику в Україні та закриття ви
канал супровід на кипить стави все
буржуйка уявна гарний покликати і
позбавляються безодня лижної захисту з них
прав зустрічається duero do суднове та
вилки влади